هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قتلت قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فتى فلسطينيا واصابت
اخر بالرصاص الحي في بلده عزون شرقا مدينه
قلقيليه بالضفه الغربيه وقالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان الفتى محمد سليم استشهد اثر
اصابته برصاصه في الظهر بينما اصيب اخر
بجروح وصفت بالحريشه
في الضفه الغربيه عما اضراب شامل حدادا
على الشهيد محمود حمدان وياتي هذا بعد
دعوات من فصائل الفلسطينيه الى اضراب شامل
في المدينه تمديدا بجرائم الاحتلال
المستمره
قال مكتب الاتحاد الاوروبي في القدس ان
دعوه وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لمحوي بلده
حوار غير مقبوله من جانبه قال ستيفان دو
شريكا المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ان موقف وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
الداعيه لمحو بلده حواره استفزازي وتحريضي
وغير مقبول
في تونس اكد المحامي مختار الجماعي في
اتصال مع الجزيره خبر اعتقال القيادي في
حركه النهضه الحبيب اللوز واللوز والقيادي
الرابع المعتقل من قاده النهضه بعد علي
العريض ونور الدين
مكتب الغنوشي سابقا اضافه الى القيادي
المستقيل من النهضه عبد الحميد لجلاصي
رفضت سلطات التونسيه السماحه لجبهه الخلاص
المعارضه بتنظيم احتجاجات يوم الاحد
المقبل بدعوى شبهه التامر على البلاد في
المقابل قالت الجبهه ان قرار والي تونس
بمنع الجبهه من التظاهر تعسفي وباطل واكدت
انها لن تستجيب للقرار وانها تتمسك بحق
التظاهر
اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
قلق بلاده من شن الحكومه التونسيه حمله
اعتقالات ضد المعارضين واضاف برايس ان بعض
المعتقلين وجهت اليهم تهم جنائيه لمجرد
انهم التقوا موظفي السفاره الامريكيه هناك
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بريانسكا الروسيه
المتاخمه للحدود الاوكرانيه مقتل اثنين من
المدنيين واصابه طفل في اطلاق نار نفذته
ما وصفها بمجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه تسللت
الى المقاطعه واحتجزت عددا من الرهائن في
متجر ومنازل
مجموعه فاجنر ان قوته اصبحت على مقربه من
مركز بخموت ونشرت وسائل اعلام تابعه
لفاجنر تعليقا لبريكوجين على فيديو لافراد
من الميليشيا وهم يرفعون علما فوق مبنى في
قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بالبيت
الابيض ضمن الولايات المتحده ستعلن عن
حزمه مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا تشمل بشكل
اساسي ذخيره لمنظومات يمتلكها الاوكرانيون
متحدثا خصوصا عن منظوماته مارس الصاروخيه
قالت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان
مديرها رافاييل جروسي يتوجه الى طهران
اليوم الجمعه لحضور اجتماعات رفيعه
المستوى بدعوه من الحكومه الايرانيه زياره
بروسيا تاتي بعد نفي ايران ما ورد في
تقرير الوكاله بشان العثور على جزيئات
يورانيوم مخصب بدرجه نقاء تقارب 90% في
مفاعل فوردو كما نقلت صحيفه وسط جورنال عن
مصادر دبلوماسيه ان هناك خلافا امريكيا
اوروبيا بشان طبيعه الرد على تخصيب ايران
لليورانيوم
وكان المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي قال
ان هناك اجماعا في الاتحاد على ضروره
مواصله المفاوضات مع ايران
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]